お堂が久しぶり元気にしてるバハムートさん元気ですよ
そっちは臨機元気日本にはもう慣れた
完璧になれたんださすがどう下日本語もさらに上手くなったね
でしょまあ日本語が結構優しいだからねあやっぱり英語の方がずっと難しいだと思い
ますそれを飲んでかなぁ英語のスペインと
プランツエーションが合わないからね例えばウェア6の b とか
日本語にはそういうのはないですからそうですね
だから日本人は英語ができないけれど僕は日本語ができますヤバくなや同源ってホント
すごいね1年間でこんなに上手くなると思う
もうなかったのだから言ったろ日本語難しいでをないですみたいだね
ていうか山本さん英語を勉強してんじゃん
英語で話しましょうかうんいいよ日本語で英語で話すの怖いでしょ
わかる同件は感がいいからねぇ日本語も考えもいいでしょ
やまったくその通りだ感じも結構
上手くなったんじゃない上手くなったよこれ見て
うつが本当がすごいねあでも同ゲソ強いと変じゃない
いとへんって何あなんでもない敬語とかも勉強している
勉強していらっしゃいますあぁどう下そこは勉強しておりますそれはわかるよいま冗談
で言ったから
上反がっぱってことを分からなかったのは米に気づいてなかったところで同源って
近くって言葉知ってる近く俺は近くを吸っていないわけないでしょ
だよね
ni